for everybody else trying today what is  the key to doing the home pretend like  your throat is in your navel can you do  a whole compression stupid whites small  scrawny God the worst avenger that was a  good way to start  o gleich fire door like water oak like  raging fire ball a smoldering fire yes  save Hulk like fire door like water kind  of like fire the whole clique raging  fire so I like smoldering fire that's  your own practice Stein and Young  Frankenstein  oh hey my name is on the inside  it doesn't take itself too seriously  sweet it's the humors not mean-spirited  and it's diverse and there's great  strong women characters and it's  everything you love about Marvel but  just that much better  [Music]  you